You'll soon notice an issue with our setup. If we walk through our entities and
render them in the list as they've been allocated, then we get into situations
that some objects will render above or below other objects, which may cause
visual issues. For instance, explosions should draw above everything else. But
with our current setup, this won't happen, depending on how our entity list is
sorted. The classic solution to this problem is to introduce a z index property
to each entity, that describes in what order an object should be rendered. If
we assume the map is at z index equal to zero, then our engine will draw
entities with lower z indexes first, such that they appear underneath objects
with higher z order values. Once we've added the z index value to each of our
entities, we have to modify the game engine class's draw function to take this
into account. So, looking at the code here, first, our draw function will, of
course, go through and draw the map. Then, as before, we walk through each of
our entities. And if it's within our viewRect, we render it to the screen. Now,
your job is to figure out how to modify this code Sort of we properly reder
zindex into account